Here's a quick story about a golf course
that almost went out of business until
they were saved by copyrightiting. So,
there's this golf course called Sylvies
Valley Golf Course in Ben, Oregon. They
actually opened in 1883, but in the
early 2000s, they were really struggling
and they needed to double their booking
rate, otherwise they would go out of
business. And then somebody on their
team had this genius idea to say, "What
if we got goats to caddy the golfers?"
Now, if you don't know what a caddy is,
it's someone who holds your clubs as
you're walking the course. And so,
that's exactly what they did. They hired
a bunch of freaking goats to hold the
clubs while they're walking the course
and it got national news attention and
now it is one of the most visited iconic
golf clubs in the United States. They
doubled their booking and they are
thriving really really well in 2026. But
I bet you're asking what in the world
does this have to do with copywriting?
Well, what they did at Sylvy's Valley
was they used a unique mechanism to
attract new attention. This is a
copywriting tactic that's been around
forever. Because if you don't have a
unique mechanism, something that is a
little bit different about your
business, then you sound, feel, and
taste like everyone else, which means
you are noise. You attract no attention,
no traffic, no eyeballs, no subscribers
until you find that one little thing
that makes you unique. So, I want you to
think about what is my goat caddy idea?
What is the one thing that I could
slightly tweak about my business that
would get people to pay attention?